i just realized that we have never hung
out
off camera that's true we've only spent
time together on your podcast and on
camera yes this is the most insincere
relationship i've ever been in i know
that we can only hang out if it's
benefiting us from someone our career
some external way we've literally never
hung out off the record but you have so
many things going on you you procreated
i am so unemployed it's ridiculous
really this is the biggest part of my
week look at what i am wearing kim
kardashian's dress from 2005. i am no
you're so desperate you look gorgeous
you're right you look like
i do
i mean this is the best it's ever gonna
get so take a good look yes
enjoy it it's got like i mean this is a
compliment a very sincere compliment
it's it's like a sexy kill bill oh i
like that
yeah that is the color is a little
ridiculous it's um it's kind of like
wetsuit material too so i like that i'm
ready for anything
ready for anything you never know what
might happen well how do you what you
have had you've had a talk show i have
had a talk show it's really cool to be
on your talk show after having my own
talk show you're doing it very well oh
well um i like where this is
but
i'm kidding so no something i think
america needs to know at home is that is
that pete does there's an audience
there's a live audience
yeah
those are real people and between
tapings you do the warm-up which means
you talk to them and most peop most talk
shows don't do that so i don't know if
they just didn't tell you yet that you
don't have to
or that you genuinely just love
performing i have to keep the plate
spinning yeah yeah yeah you know what i
mean you need that much attention
you can't not be performing for one
second well that's the genius is i've
masked it as a service it's like i have
to give and give really i'm just a [ __ ]
right
well no we're sitting next to me in this
dress you're definitely not the [ __ ]
here but
um i would try on that but i respect
that because
sweeps week is coming up sure um here's
the thing though i have so much respect
for that because you seem so rel when i
had a talk show i was very stressed out
i was very anxious you what are you
taking
i mean you look really relaxed i really
appreciate that uh i take a few tylenol
pm every morning just to take the edge
off i respect that yeah you don't you
don't want to go to bed but you're just
kind of like in a daze all day yeah
i mean and you're just kind of wearing
your pajamas
i mean you're just sort of like
i like how casual andy richter said i
looked like a stereo salesman
you can't help notice you're uh looking
at the bows right there
yeah i mean you're undershirt not even i
mean there's you know whose only job is
to make sure that he looks good and i
feel like she's not gonna put this on
her resume
i mean the top but i mean i bro i've
been getting ready for three hours all
right so i just you know i understand
this is casual yeah you win i respect
that i think i look good and i'm very
happy with wardrobe but if you came over
my house yeah 3 a.m if there was cameras
there i would come
on a new show break up my buddy
it's on fxx cuddle in with pete yeah
cuddling with pete i like that [ __ ] you
get a lot of pheromones and paws vibes
that pause
by the way you can't abbreviate
everything you're saying people need to
understand
sure can
i feel like you have your own language
going you have your own like world but i
feel like yeah it's obviously no no i
didn't mean it like that it's working
for my life yeah you know life is dull
uh unlike javier bardem and vicki
christina is that how you pronounce it
javier oh yeah
what do you say what is it i don't know
i'm not
xavier
caviar bardem is that that's it always
thinking of sketch i don't respect that
car
caviar bardem you guys just this is how
the creative process happens you just
witnessed it that's your sketch for the
next episode
that's that's going to be a horrible
sketch yeah
yeah
i'm just thinking about this game yeah
no stay see oh stay with me here's the
thing i love how you're so like playful
and all over the place and
like crazy
again super unprofessional i love it
as a guest you're just like having panic
attacks you're like i i have a whole set
of things i'm supposed to talk about oh
well yeah
we talked about that on your podcast you
like you're more of a control person i
said we're on television pete yes
there's
this is real this is a real show
i mean this isn't your podcast in your
attic anymore you're famous now you have
to just step it up man
i could take it or leave it
i mean
i'm kidding